Speaker 1: Okay. Last like side, ancillary story
from this event that took place in Michigan,
this Trump rally in Michigan, which is just
completely and totally wild. I do have a couple
of mike pillow clips here. Mike Pillow, also known
as Mike Lindell, the CEO and founder of Mypillow.
He was at the Trump rally in Warren, Michigan.
He was interviewed by right side broadcasting,
and he made the claim that the FBI found him
at the Hardees where they seized this phone
because they illegally put some kind of a
tracking device on him. Now, does he have
any proof of this? No, he doesn't.
Speaker 6: It was like 1:00 or. No,
the guy. Yes. 1130.
Speaker 2: How did they
know where you were? Where they following.
Speaker 6: You? No, we have no idea. So we.
Speaker 2: Got behind?
Speaker 6: No, we pulled into a Hardee's. How
did they know? They tracked me illegally.
They tracked their tracking device out or
my phone. We don't know yet. We're trying to
get to the bottom of that. But what they did.
Speaker 1: We just don't know. You know, if
they had a suspicion that pillow was in town,
they probably just said, let's just
wait at Hardee's. He's probably bound
to show up eventually. In all seriousness,
isn't the tracking device his phone? Like,
we all carry these phones around and we mostly
all have GPS enabled. I guess he's willingly
carrying it around until the FBI took it. Is
Mike Pillow really not making too much sense?
And that. Oh, one more pillow clip from the
rally here. He was kind of jumping on the
some Republicans are bad train saying that the
Republicans nominated in Georgia aren't good.
And by the way, what he means by that is that the
Republicans in Georgia weren't as willing as he
wanted them to be to try to just give Georgia's
electoral votes to Trump, even though Biden won.
Speaker 6: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines. Okay.
Speaker 1: Anyway, here's the explanation.
Speaker 6: I don't care. You know, you guys
don't. In Georgia, you're stuck with those three
because the Republicans won better ones. To me,
there's nothing worse than evil. Evil
doesn't show sides. Evil doesn't show.
Oh, you're a Republican or you're a Democrat. No,
it holds no bounds. So you have the, I believe,
the worst three Republicans in history down
in Georgia ever, ever. And because of the
cover up that they've done. And then here you.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So what he means is, I would
like them to have given Trump Georgia, even though
Biden won it. That's effectively what Mypillow is
saying here. And then meanwhile, by the way, if
he's saying these three are the bad candidates,
by definition, it means that Herschel Walker
in Georgia must be a good candidate, which is
laughable and also really, really scary. So that's
all the stuff I want to talk about from Michigan.
We heard from Trump, we heard from the audience
members. We heard from Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
and now we heard from Mike Pillow. You tell me
who's the scariest? I kind of lean towards it's
the audience, because without the audience,
none of these people get any attention.
But because they have followers, they have
influence. And that is truly, truly sick stuff.